the secret to making great food is to
ensure you lock in every last ounce of
flavor in that pan and this spicy
sausage rice does exactly that
take these spicy sausages and pierce
that skin because i want all that
delicious spicy sausage meat out of this
casing
and you get more flavor from the sausage
when you take them out the casing
sausage is ready turn on the gas
bread onion less acidic than a big white
spanish onion and a lot more flavoursome
tablespoon of olive oil a tablespoon
only because i want all that fat coming
out the sausages to sort of really help
flavor the onions onions in
and the onions go in first because you
can never rush cooking an onion it's
really important to sort of give them
five to six minutes in the pan so you
can really start to caramelize them
my mouth and my pepper
slice around
wasting nothing
i want to see that sort of
little core those pips in the center no
fine diced pepper the rice is going to
be cooking for 20 minutes so i want the
veg to sort of have texture after it's
cooked peppers in
a bit of garlic two nice cloves
just slap down
off with the shell
garlic in
[Music]
now i want to turn up the gas get the
pan nice and hot because the minute that
sausage goes in everything cools down
and you'll end up boiling the peppers
and the onions and the garlic so heat up
to maximum and then just make a well
in the center
in
now
start stirring quickly
this is where you get so much more bang
for your buck out of sausages because
the skins off and the real flavor of
that
spicy italian sausage is going to come
through
what's great about this recipe is that
you can use any type of sausage to get
the flavor and the heat you want i've
gone for the spicy italian but it's just
as good with merguez or chorizo
a teaspoon
paprika in give it a really nice smoky
flavor
rice in and we're going to sort of
basically sear the rice we call it in
the kitchen blasting the rice where we
sort of soda the rice for 30 seconds and
it takes on all that flavor
[Music]
next white
wine so the wine sort of deglazes the
pan and washes all that flavor from the
bottom of the pan into the rice
stock in bring it up to the boil turn it
down and let it simmer
double stop to rice
turn that gas down
and let it simmer
for 12 to 15 minutes
and just give it the occasional stir
keep an eye on it now get ready to
finish it
slice spring onions diced sweet juicy
tomatoes and roughly chop earthy flat
leaf parsley
spring is in tomatoes in
off with the gas really important
otherwise everything becomes overcooked
flat leaf parsley in but look
at the volume in that pan now that
is an amazing way to take spicy italian
sausages
to a completely different level
beautiful
[Music]
you